rappelez-vous suite à l' incendie de la
station d'épuration d'achères survenu le
3 juillet dernier des poissons asphyxié
des anguilles ou des perches morte
flotter est derrière moi
aujourd'hui deux mois après tout a été à
ramasser au total 7,5 tonnes ont été
enlevés de la scène deux mois après
l'eau de la seine est plus propre la
qualité bactériologique des eaux est au
moins aussi bonne qu auparavant suite à
l' incendie dont la cause n'est pas
encore connu la capacité de traitement
de l'usiné de seine aval s'est réduite
l'incendié a touché les yvelines et le
val d'oise les élus restent très entier
notamment en cas de nouvel épisode
pluvieux et dans la mesure où sa
capacité de traitement aujourd'hui et
est atteinte en risque de se retrouver
malgré tout avec des problèmes assez
sérieux dans la période qui vient dans
les deux ou trois ans qui viennent le
siaap a débuté son travail pour que l'
usine seine aval retrouve une capacité
proches de la situation existante avant
l' incendie
on sera prêt en tous les cas avant la
période estivale puisque là on a plus de
danger de mortalité dans la scène de
poisson déjà les mesures qui ont été
prises sont suffisantes et surtout on va
passer de 100 mètres cubes des débits de
la scène à 300 mètres cubes avec des
socquettes à 27 degrés au mois de
juillet qui vont être à 10 15 degrés
donc une capacité d'auto épuration de la
scène importante qui préservera la vie
biologique du fleuve
les travaux de la reconstruction de
l'unité débuteront en 2021 après une
phase de nettoyage et de diagnostic
le coût de la reconstruction est estimé
entre 80 et 100 millions d'euros une
réunion d'information s'est tenue à la
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
une troisième réunion d'information
suite à l' incendie de la station
d'épuration d'achères survenu le 3
juillet dernier
aujourd'hui deux mois après un point
ressort de cette réunion
de nouvelles dispositions d'alert des
populations justement le préfet des
yvelines jean jacques brot s'est
positionné le pays
le plan particulier d'intervention a été
présenté aux différentes communes
une signature est prévue en septembre
concernant ce pays je le rappelle le
plan particulier d'intervention une
réunion
déroulera le 11 septembre en
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
à 14h30